OLIVIER DE WECK: My
name is Olivier de Weck.
And I'm a professor here at MIT
in the AeroAstro Department,
also known as the Department of
Aeronautics and Astronautics.
And I've been in the
department since 2001.
And my passion is
aerospace vehicle,
anything that flies,
airplanes, rockets, satellites.
And it's been my passion
since I was a kid.
So I grew up in
Switzerland in the Alps.
And the Alps, especially
in the wintertime
when it's a clear
night, are amazing.
You look up at the night sky.
And you can see the stars.
You can see the Milky Way.
And as a kid, it
really inspired me.
I wanted to do
something with stars.
Initially, I thought I was
going to be an astronomer.
But then, I really
liked building things.
And so aviation,
rockets, spacecraft
really became my passion.
Later, I did my
military service.
And I worked on planes, flight
operations, maintenance,
repair, really learning
planes in and out,
the engines, the hydraulic
system, the avionics,
working with others
and pilots to keep
airplanes flying safely.
And that really was the
origin of my passion
for systems engineering.